[Musique]
on arrive on investit beaucoup pour
changer nos systèmes de chaudière isoler
des vêtements pour moins consommer de
bâtiment mais ce qui est sans doute le
plus efficace encore c'est de chauffer
les bâtiments ou les rafraîchir avec une
énergie gratuite naturelle qui est donc
la chaleur qui a dans les eaux des
égouts
[Musique]
c'est un investissement d'un virgule 6
millions d'euros et qui va nous
permettre d'économiser jusqu'à 2300
tonnes de CO2 donc c'est beaucoup de CO2
et qui va nous permettre de chauffer 60%
du chauffage de 5 bâtiments publics
[Musique]
on en est actuellement 14 autres qui
sont à l'étude et on ne va en chercher
peut-être d'autres qui ont coupé 50 ou
100 de un mis en œuvre à Paris dans les
années à venir
[Musique]
on a un réseau avec énormément de
kilomètres d'égouts sur des grands
linéaires et qui sont des tuyaux qui
sont bien adaptés pour ça où on peut
passer hauteur d'homme on peut faire les
travaux pour les installer c'est plus
facile qu'ailleurs et aussi parce que la
Ville de Paris on a des services notre
direction et construction Vic le service
de l'énergie c'est 300 personnes on a
beaucoup d'ingénieurs on a un service
d'innovation à la mairie qui permettent
de développer ce type de projet
[Musique]